michael was an amazing husband author
and provider the community is
remembering nevada highway patrol
trooper micah may
good evening and thanks so much for
joining us at six i'm vanessa murphy
and i'm christian casadas today the
community gathered for a procession
through the valley
a service was held for may at central
church in henderson
hundreds were in attendance according to
joe muller who gives us a look at how
may
was remembered
he genuinely loved helping
and protecting people and showed it
in the way he treated the public a
community says goodbye to a fallen hero
i doubt but only the minute few
would step out as he did
and more than once i have been told he
did so
from las vegas mayor carolyn goodman to
the head of the nevada highway patrol
colonel and carpenter
local leaders wanted to honor the man
who leaves behind a wife and children
to his wife joanna kids raylan and
melody
you carry his name which will live on
through the children he loves so dearly
it was his family trooper may saw just
before his life was taken
just before trooper may went on his last
call he learned that his family was
shopping
and surprised them all during his break
he left though because he felt like he
was needed by his fellow troopers
that one snapshot in a life that by all
accounts was truly honorable
speaks volumes for him both of may's
brothers shared stories about their
childhoods together
we've spent a lot of time in the woods
too micah loved to find
the tallest trees and climb them
and he would climb all the way to the
top and never show any fear of heights
trooper may was described as a patriot
and a hero he did not only protect and
save lives during his
career he also saved more after trooper
may's final act of grace ended with the
donation of his heart
liver and both kidneys which saved four
lives joe mohler 8 news now a truly
emotional day for sure well you can tell
how appreciated trooper may was
a lot of people stopped to salute the
procession and law enforcement agencies
from all over the country
were here to honor him as well vanessa
and after today's funeral
a procession made its way to trooper
may's final resting place
sasha loftis was there for his burial
she joins us from palm eastern cemetery
hi sasha
hearts were heavy here today as trooper
micah may was officially
laid to rest the end of an entire day
dedicated to his selfless service
here in southern nevada trooper maze
casket was brought in
and saluted by members of law
enforcement the ceremony also involved a
helicopter flyover
before trooper may was lowered into the
ground and his widow joanna may was
handed a folded american flag so she and
her children
could say their final goodbyes nevada
highway patrol says this moment wasn't
just
important to honor trooper may but also
to remind his family that all of las
vegas
is behind them this is about the family
it's important that they know
how important micah was to this
community
and how important he was to all of us
officers that wear the badge as painful
as it is for me to
really relive that horrible day it's
important to me that
the community sees
what mike has stood for and what we've
lost
trooper smacka also said this beautiful
event is a symbol of our city's heart
an ability to come together in times of
unimaginable grief
there was also a riderless horse here to
symbolize a fallen hero
and trooper smackus said though trooper
may is gone he will never
be forgotten reporting in las vegas
tonight sasha loftis
8 news now trooper may grew up in
greenfield massachusetts in 2008 he
tested for the nevada highway patrol
and moved to las vegas
we're taking a look at the latest
numbers in the pandemic the nevada
health response reported 26
deaths and 1 thousand 299
new cases that brings the statewide
total to over
363 thousand cases today the death toll
surpassed
6 thousand cases and today governor
steve sisilak issued a statement
on the death toll he said quote today we
have lost more than
6 000 nevadans to covet 19 since the
start of the pandemic in early 2020.
this is another significant and
heartbreaking milestone for our state
he went on to say i want to encourage
all nevadans who have not yet done so to
please consider getting the covet 19
vaccine
as soon as possible the vaccines are
free safe
and incredibly effective at preventing
severe illness
hospitalization and death well remember
the surge in covet 19 cases and
hospitalizations
last summer the state reports numbers
right now have surpassed
that leaders in the state's fight
against kovid 19 held a virtual briefing
this afternoon
an area which is causing major concern
right now is the health care system
the hospital association reports people
who are not
vaccinated are showing up to hospitals
sick with covet 19
and putting a strain on the system and
they make up about a third of patients
in the intensive care
units the hospital association also
reports overcrowding in hospitals
and staffing shortages at five in
southern nevada
again because of the unvaccinated
governor steve sisilak saying thursday
the delta variant is spreading like
wildfire
and that almost every person who has
died of covid19 in the state this year
was not vaccinated in clark county about
47 percent of those eligible for the
vaccine have received it but leaders say
that's not enough
because again we are seeing a surge
their message
get vaccinated that takes
not just a government directive or a
mandate or
private sector that takes um the public
and everyone involved to really all meet
in the middle and make sure that
we're getting shots and arms um those
who have shots and arms will
likely never end up in a hospital for
covet that's the facts and so we have to
focus on that path because the other
alternative is looking pretty scary
governor siselek says he's not leaning
toward a vaccine mandate or vaccine
passport right now but he is asking for
businesses and
organizers to come up with solutions and
we may slowly
see a vaccine requirement for more
specific situations like for health care
workers
on college campuses and more and another
reminder the vaccine
is free and if you feel that the vaccine
or covet 19 testing are not accessible
to you
you can contact the state and put in a
request
they may try to set up a location near
you we'll have a link
at eightnewsnow.com vanessa the town of
alco has voted not to comply
with governor sisilek's reinstated mass
mandate according to the elko daily free
press
a crowded audience applauded the county
commission's vote on wednesday
to resist the masks now the move applies
to the
unincorporated areas and not to the
cities of elko
carlin wells and west wendover right now
only 29.7 percent of elko's population
is vaccinated
[Music]
a man is behind bars tonight after
police say he shot and killed a man
earlier this week
27-year-old hugo gonzalez was arrested
yesterday and is charged with one count
of murder
on monday metro responded to a fight
near tropicana and lindell
that's when they found 30-year-old james
edgar may with over
10 gunshot wounds may was taken to the
hospital
where he was pronounced dead three
people are facing murder and kidnapping
charges in the death of 27
year old roy jagers of las vegas his
body was found in cathedral canyon in
nye county
investigators say heather pate was his
neighbor and believed he hurt her child
that's when they lured him into a home
and beat him
all three suspects are being held at the
night county detention center without
bail
southern nevada home prices are breaking
records the average price of a home now
at the 400
000 mark that's according to a report
released today from las vegas realtors
lvr reported the median price of
existing
single-family homes sold through its
multiple listing service during july
was 405 000 that tops the previous
record set in june
the median home price is up 22.7
from one year ago well wow well vanessa
from
frontier airlines is the latest company
announcing a vaccine policy
effective october 1st all employees must
be fully vaccinated
against covet 19 or provide proof of a
negative test
on a regular base frontier is also
encouraging customers to get vaccinated
with an update to its popular friends
fly free program
discounts and bonus miles are up for
grabs for those that are fully
vaccinated
christian tonight cancellations continue
for spirit airlines
while they hope to resume more flights
yesterday more
issues today we just checked mccarran's
website
many flights show canceled both
departing and arrivals
the airline released a statement stating
the delays and cancellations were due to
weather and operational
challenges and contrary to internet
rumors the airline's pilots and baggage
handlers
are not on strike more cancellations are
expected
through the weekend a traffic alert now
an ongoing construction project is
causing some closures on the north end
of the strip
next week las vegas boulevard between
elvis presley and sahara
will be limited to one lane in each
direction from 7 a.m
on monday to 2 p.m next friday drivers
should expect some delays
and use an alternate route if possible
preparations for the demolition of the
aging desert in road
bridge begin next week drivers should
expect several lane and ramp closures
between boulder highway and flamingo
road
ndot asks those using the roads to use
caution and take a detour if possible
at 28newsnow.com for a full list of
dates times
and areas closed captioning not
show you available they're knocking off
the to-do list
a little bit of wind to wind up the week
we'll fill you in on the haze and some
possible wildfire smoke for the weekend
your most accurate weather now forecast
live
by silver state refrigeration in hvac
this is eight news now
live at six with denise valdez
brian loftus ted florendo and chris
matthews
eight news now live at six live
local now as kids gear up for a new
school year there are several new
schools opening along with several that
have just moved into new facilities
madison kimbrough stopped by two
elementary schools that held their
ribbon cuttings today inside of their
new buildings
she joins us live in front of george e
harris elementary at sand hill and twain
madison pretty exciting for students
right
yes i got a tour and take a look for
yourself it's quite pretty out here and
the inside is quite stunning too
the parents and kids i spoke with were
very pleased with how everything looked
i feel pretty happy the classroom looked
awesome
it had a lot of space students parents
and staff
excited for what this new year will
bring with brand new replacement schools
friday a sneak peek inside george e
harris and farren elementary schools
it's exciting for the kids to be in a
new building
so that they can gain a quality
education in addition mabel hogard
elementary
myrtle tate elementary and sandy valley
high all have new campuses too
superintendent dr jesus jarrah sharing
his excitement about these new
facilities
our work has continued and has
intensified during covenants we're going
to deliver
world class education in the 21st
century classroom
mamashima carter says having her kids
back in the classroom is a much needed
step in the right direction
they were doing the distance learning
for so long
and part of me didn't think didn't know
how they were going to really come out
of it
but to see that everybody got feet on
the ground running getting back in
school 100 percent now
it means a lot to me two brand new
schools opened doors on monday
berry and june gunderson middle school
in the southwest valley
as well as hannah marie brown elementary
in henderson
and as a reminder school does begin on
monday so give yourself plenty of time
out on the road police will be out in
full force making sure that you're not
speeding in any of these school zones so
be careful
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now
all right thank you madison well today
representative susie lee visited the
vaccination site at canarelli middle
school
this site offers not only copin 19
vaccines but also back to school shots
representative lee along with dr lewin
and dr jara are urging all nevadans to
get vaccinated
they also highlighted the importance of
keeping students healthy and protected
as they return to the new school year
[Music]
and let's get a look at weather with
nate tannenbaum nate i have a friend who
wants to go hiking tomorrow
i think it's too hot right well when you
get up to the higher elevations it might
be okay but if you're staying down here
definitely you got to be very careful
vanessa and whatever you're doing
outdoors
especially with the possibility of some
smoke and haze coming in from southern
california wildfires now
this view is from our camera on top of
the red rock resort got a palm tree up
on the roof
looking out across the city so the wind
that we've got this afternoon is doing a
great job of clearing things out but you
can see the haze beginning to settle
and that wind is blowing in some of that
smoke officially we're down to 103
degrees at mccarran but we wanted to
check
your neighborhood see what's going on a
little bit warmer henderson hanging onto
106. same for the strip downtown
aliante and the air force base drop into
104 green valley 105.
99 under the century mark in summerlin
but everybody is experiencing these 10
to 20 mile an hour winds
you want to escape that you do head up
to mount charleston where it is a cooler
79
but still some gusty winds up there as
well and
a couple of locations have actually had
their temperature go up over the last
hour
an hour ago death valley was at 114 up
to 117 right now laughlin at 111
double digits in cedar city also up in
ely
caliente lincoln county good evening
you're at 93 97
for kingman so we made it to 106
today and every day we have a
temperature at or above 100 the folks at
silver state refrigeration in hvac
donated a hundred dollars to pets
and vets that 106 a couple of degrees
above normal no threat to the record
we're going to try to get tomorrow's low
a little bit closer to normal because
when you're waking up close to 90
degrees it's kind of uncomfortable
so the wind will move on yesterday's
wind kind of settled down came back
again this afternoon but
it is bringing in some smoke and haze
from southern california wildfires
don't think it's going to completely
obscure our visibility but it probably
will be
noticeable got a couple of severe
thunderstorm watches still for parts of
south dakota some strong storms moving
through there
that's about the worst of it for your
family and friends across the country
so for tonight again we'll try to get
you to 82 tomorrow morning watch for
some haze
still breezes maybe to 10 or 15. and
your eight day forecast goes like this
up to 108 from 106 and still maybe some
smoke and haze
that will continue on sunday but we're
going to get it out of here
for back to school monday right about
normal for the high at 104
maybe up to 105 tuesday we are talking
about the possibility of monsoon
moisture returning next week so far
we're just going to call it partly
cloudy certainly worth keeping an eye on
get out there and stay safe on your
weekend christian
all right nate thank you so much well
the two largest water reservoirs in the
united states continue to hit
historic lows today lake mead is at 1067
feet which is actually 36 percent full
the second largest lake powell on the
utah arizona border
it's also at a record low at about 32
percent full lake powell has
had to close ramps and force house
boards off the water
that has been hurting tourism there and
left the businesses scrambling
a federal water shortage is expected to
be declared on the colorado river
in the next few weeks we'll still ahead
at 6 30 california's largest wildfire
has destroyed another community and
threatens even more the destructive
power
of the dixie fire but first switching
gears john joins us now here in studio
with the first look at sports hey john
hey there christian
this weekend raider greats get a moment
of a lifetime all the while current
raiders on the roster
try to carve their roles sports is next
off point hotel casino and spa
[Music]
when waller is away who's going to make
a play that's been the mandated question
at raiders training camp this week the
silver and black field they have enough
fire power
to overcome the absence of their best
player darren waller the raiders are
still five weeks away from the first
regular season game so we can pump the
brakes on the panic but for the past
three days
darren waller has been curiously missing
from practice the silver and blackfield
they have enough receivers and tight
ends to fill the void
foster moreau is a passionate presence
and the reverend took the pulpit and
preached today
people don't rise to the occasion you
know it's kind of that's
it's not really a real thing heroes
aren't really made in the moment
guys normally fall to the level of their
training especially during a sudden
change
so when we don't have our centerpiece
out there everyone else has to fall to
the level of the training that they've
done over the past seven months
and so at that point guys kind of have
to step
up and if you need a different leader
that's fine
but you have to take responsibility for
yourself
to be able to handle a little bit more
of a snap share
but also do your job and just try to
hone in on
the details can i get a witness foster
thank you now they are known for their
success in silver and black but they
will be remembered in bronze
the pro football hall of fame induction
ceremony is this weekend in canton ohio
two raider greats will be front and
center and receiving the honor of a
lifetime
there are only eight members of the 2021
class but two hit
home for raider nation super bowl
winning coach tom flores finally gets
his
chance to be on stage in canton he's
joined by charles woodson a defensive
back who started his career in oakland
and came back to finish it this weekend
as a tribute to the defensive back and
his mentor
you know with the raiders just being
drafted you know fourth overall
was a pretty big deal and to me it was
really all about the relationships and
the guys
that i was able to play alongside out
there legends of the game tim brown's
here
the only thing i'm missing here is
willie brown this time of year
i remember being on sidelines and he
would always leave and come to the hall
of fame this time of year during
training camp
then he'd come back and tell me about it
and say charles i can't wait till you go
in i'm going to be right there
las vegas joey gala was feeling it
yesterday when a player is traded at the
mlb deadline it's because he is seen as
a catalyst
for playoff contention it's a lot of
pressure magnify that by a thousand
when it comes to the yankees the bishop
gorman grad was traded last week from
the texas rangers but yet to hit a home
run in pinstripes
last night he faced foreman former
gorman grad paul seawall
of the mariners it was a las vegas
reunion
and a historic one joey gallo went las
vegas launching
giving his team the yankees the lead and
sending the bronx
into a frenzy what a moment bonanza grad
chris bryant continues to thrive for his
team san francisco
bonanza high school grad yes started a
ninth inning rally with a double
and then in the tenth delivered a
game-winning hit bryant
the giant fits and bryce harper
only 28 years old but last night the las
vegas high school
product hit his 250th career home run
the milestone is impressive but also
validating as it happened against his
former team the nationals
as his former fan base was booing him
the entire
game back to you christian all right
thank you john well coming up at 6
30 travel chaos continues for spirit
airlines and its customers as
of this morning the low-cost airline has
already canceled more than
250 flights we hear more from those
frustrated passengers
and state and federal officials continue
to implement
policies to try to slow the spread of
covid19
urging more people to get vaccinated
this as the case's nationwide
skype
install 702 get more
this is your weather now good evening
with christian continues and vanessa
murphy nathan tallenbaum in the 8 news 9
weather center in for ted florent a lot
of blue sky today
but some winds gusting up to 30 miles an
hour we're also going to be talking
about the possibility of some widespread
haze
maybe some smoke from southern
california wildfires off and on all
weekend long
this is 8 news now live local
now now at 6 30 another day of delays
and cancellations for spirit airlines
will look at when things will resolve
slowing the spread of covet more
mandates and rules are in place tonight
we'll tell you the latest requirements
and positive news on the job front
tonight as the economy continues to
improve
now this is 8 news now live at 6
30 live local now it's another bad day
for passengers on spirit airlines the
company canceled more flights as they
try to fix what they are calling
operational challenges good evening and
thank you for joining us here at 6 30
i'm christian casadis
and i'm vanessa murphy it's becoming a
common occurrence for passengers on
spirit airlines
the hustle and bustle at the airport
drop-off are more of a bust because of
canceled flights
spirit has canceled hundreds of flights
nationwide
they say they're working as fast as
possible to fix the problem so they can
get people to where they need to be
in a statement tuesday morning a spirit
spokesman said the airline is working to
find solutions
to what they're calling operational
challenges on monday they denied rumors
that the cancellations were due to
a pilot strike i think a lot of people
are devastated
they really are devastated and i always
did like spirit
i'm very disappointed that they would do
this to their people
airport officials suggest checking in
before you get to the airport sign up
for notifications
and get to the airport early at least
two hours for domestic
and three for international flights
the delta variant is driving a new surge
in covet cases with experts warning the
numbers could go
higher that's triggering new mask
mandates including
for some schools now the cdc says daily
covet 19 cases
have reached the highest total since
february the number of new cases topped
106
000 yesterday experts expect the numbers
will only rise
in the face of large events such as the
the motorcycle rally now underway in
south dakota
i keep telling people don't think you
can run out the game clock
it's not going to happen ultimately this
virus will keep circulating
until it finds you a new study from the
cdc finds covet 19 vaccines offer higher
protection from the virus
than previous infection the job market
continues to improve for a second
straight month employers added hundreds
of thousands of workers
according to the labor department 943
000 jobs were added to the economy last
month
the unemployment rate dropped 5.9
percent in june to
5.4 percent in july slightly lower than
what economists had
expected president biden says the
economy is headed
in the right direction the unemployment
rate is the lowest since the pandemic
hit
the bottom line is this what we're doing
is working
it appears more people are returning to
the office as well
13.2 percent of employees worked
remotely in july
down from 14.4 percent in june
as the tokyo olympics begin to wind down
and covet cases in tokyo spike
the question becomes what happens when
everyone travels back home marilynna
belarus spoke with an infection disease
expert
in the u.s to find out it's not an
optimistic outlook from dr stephen
thomas but it's a realistic one
you know we are one of the global hot
spots as athletes media staff coaches
and olympic organizers prepare to travel
back to the states
dr thomas says things have changed they
should understand
they're coming back to a different a
different place this is thanks to the
delta variant which spreads faster than
many of the original strains of covet
19.
as much covet activity as you're seeing
in japan and in tokyo specifically
you're you're going from you're going
from a warm spot to a hot spot
and here in tokyo we have seen athletes
test positive and then not be able to
compete
thomas says that could be seen as an
incentive to get a vaccine but he says
the bigger incentive should be your life
i am not a dramatic person or a
melodramatic person but really
the incentive is your life this
new virus variant in addition to being
more infectious we feel very
confident is also much more severe
thomas is glad the games happened even
with the challenges and changes
i am personally glad that they you know
that
that they did it and they and they they
tried very hard to
mitigate risks so they could do it in
tokyo i'm eddie alana balloras
still ahead best in show tickets are on
sale for the animal foundation's 18th
annual event
the details on the other side of the
break oh that's a great show hey a
little bit of wind to wind up the week
we'll fill you in on the haze
possible wildfire spoke for the weekend
most accurate weather now forecast
live
renovation on 8 news now
live at 6 30. this is eight news
now tickets are now on sale for the
animal foundation's 18th annual best in
show
dogs and new this year kittens will
compete in several categories all of the
animals will be available for option
it will take place sunday september 26th
at the thomas and max center
tickets are five dollars the event will
also be live streamed
for those who can't make it first friday
returns downtown tonight it's in the
arts district from
5 to 11 p.m the festival's theme for
august is good vibes only
it's free to attend there will be plenty
of art entertainment and food
well 24-hour bingo at arizona charlize
is back it starts
next friday august 13th beginning at 9am
now the event will include a raffle with
the grand prize drawing during the 7 a.m
on saturday there will also be a chance
to win free slot play
bingo rainbows and mystery prizes all
bingo players who participate during the
7 a.m session on saturday
will receive a branded t-shirt who
doesn't like bingo
a rock and roll legend will be bringing
his talents as vegas's
newest resident gene simmons has
confirmed with 8 news now a kiss
residency happening december 27 through
february
inside planet hollywood in addition to
his singing career he also
draws but he doesn't really consider
himself an artist why not
his art is on display at the grand canal
shops
coming up the beginning of the school
year is just days away we hear from a
doctor about why he's raising awareness
for children's mental health
green valley summerlin and centennial 8
news now
live at 6 30 with brian loftus denise
valdez
and ted florendo 8 news now live at 6 30
live local now we're just days away
before
thousands of students return to the
classrooms for their first day
of the new school year now one key
factor to watch monitor your child's
mental health i spoke to dr sheldon
jacobs on behalf
of hope means nevada on why they are
raising awareness
on this issue we're living in
unchartered waters and so i think that
all the uncertainty that's come with
living
throughout this pandemic the different
changes in terms of when it comes to
mass you're
not having to wear a mask and all the
different mandates that are out there
it's just caused a lot of
anxiety a lot of uncertainty and so as a
result of that
you know it's led to mental health
struggles for for many people
so now we're you know we're trying to
get our kids to go back to
somewhat normal environment of school um
however you know it's not really that
normal because they're going to be
forced to wear a mask and we think about
just the past 18 months many of them
have not been in the classroom for such
a long period of time so i think just
that
change or that adjustment can add to
anxiety it can add to other mental
health related struggles
some things that you may want to look
out for is if your child is experiencing
like
more tantrums than usual or more
emotional outbursts
that could be a sign something more iron
on the line is gone or if they are
experiencing uh you know this behavior
where they're more clingy
you know where they don't want to be
left alone or and that is you know kind
of unusual for them
uh you know that could be another sign
this is a big one for for some teens uh
where
if they're starting to experiment with
substances so substance use
could be a sign or sexually acting out
uh could be another sign
a big one and i've seen this a lot over
the course of the past 18
18 months because of the pandemic and
that is a change in academic functioning
so if you have a student
who's normally a straight a student or
an ab student and all of a sudden
they're
filming most of their classes you know
it could be a sign of something else
that might be going on
if a child is you know reporting that
they have thoughts of wanting to harm
themselves or harm others
again that's definitely a sign that
something you know is
underlying and so if they're trying to
hurt themselves in particular you know
you may want to look at you know
reaching out to a resource professional
um contacting a hospital depending on
the severity of that
i mean the first thing would be if you
have private insurance i reach out to
your to your
insurance provider uh most insurance
cards on the back of the id
uh there's a member id i'm sorry a
member services number that you can call
and ask for
a a printout of providers that accept
that respective insurance if you don't
have private insurance but have maybe
medicaid uh or you don't have don't have
insurance at all
211 is another great resource and with
two on one you can text
two on one and you'll get a a link to
services you can call the number two 211
as well if you see any
changes in behavior in your kids you
know you do not want to ignore it
you want to be proactive versus reactive
all starts with sleep
sleep is such a huge one and i can't
stress that enough no kids should be
getting anywhere from
you know nine ten hours of sleep at
night the video games the you know being
on the tablets
uh right up until bedtime that also can
impact sleep you know there's been a lot
of research that's been focused on that
over the past couple years
in terms of you know having like an hour
or two in between you know the time you
stop
you know you playing or using the
devices to the time
you know you go to sleep